we're looking at a hot 103 today into  saturday as well sunday 100 and 99 for  the fourth of july all those nice  fireworks that everybody is so anxious  to set off the safe and sane ones should  be fine in the wind but just watch for  the sparks and illegal fireworks with  these 25 30 mile per hour winds this  weekend they're going to be so dangerous  and they are  illegal to shoot off all those fireworks  the big ones in the air so good luck in  your neighborhood please hopefully  neighbors are going to be smart and sane  all right we've got those drier  southwest winds keep pushing the monsoon  closer and over to the four corners away  from us we have fire weather warnings  now issued for saturday morning through  monday night  so two full days of dry gusty conditions  where fire conditions are going to be  just right if a fire gets started it's  going to be very hard to get it under  control